uh so uh the topic of my prayer uh of my
talk today is uh network construction
and inference uh as an elegant approach
to understand disease pathogenesis
right so uh to begin with uh first of
all i uh wanted to uh define uh or
explain uh what do we understand by
systems biology because uh till you
understand systems biology this is the
subject this is a broader umbrella under
which we study uh about networks
as uh mr barua has given you an uh
introduction about data and the
data from
biological sciences and how uh those
data can be uh used for getting uh
meaningful insights from those data and
those certain predictions etc so that is
uh one aspect
of
of data of data science in our big data
in biology today where we use aiml uh
techniques and the other aspect other
end is where other application is rather
uh where we use systems biology modeling
and simulations or network analysis or
network uh studies
uh uh to get inferences so so the
objective is more or less same in both
the cases where
in the in the previous one we uh
we
get insights and those predictions using
aiml methods here we use various
mathematical
uh and theoretical uh modeling
strategies or network network or
topological analysis
um for in systems biology to get those
insights right so there are two ends uh
there are two uh ways by which you can
dig out
meaning or from those big data in
biology
so that you as you all know there is a
huge uh
data explosion everywhere uh in
biological uh sciences or biomedical
sciences
and
those data has are generated by using
high throughput
techniques um
various high throughput techniques like
for example ngs
then
mass spectrometry uh etc then uh so uh
these data needs to get some meaning
right so otherwise um we if we don't get
uh
any conclusion or inference from those
data uh analysis is of no use uh so
that's the main person main aim so
systems biology is one such area uh
though it is not a very uh new field of
science um uh it has uh it has been
studied uh like it has been studying in
um
this has been you uh most researchers
have been using these systems biology
approaches uh from the very beginning
itself uh since uh biology has been
started studying so initially it used to
be called as uh
theoretical or mathematical uh biology
now uh with the with the data now with
the all those omics uh data that we have
or other other proteomics or
metabolomics data that we have they had
this whole systems biology has taken a
new new phase
right so that's how systems biology uh
is involved these days in every
university so you go abroad in
universities they have a systems biology
uh department or systems biology
research groups right so
uh let's start with some basics uh the
with what what we understand for the
beginners who has never heard who has
never uh come across this uh
uh this field of science that systems
what is systems biology systems biology
uh is the is what we um when we study
the components of a of any biological
system
um and their interactions and how those
interactions uh actually give rise to uh
to certain functions and behavior of
that system so those behaviors are
coherent behavior so they keep on
interacting among themselves and give
rise to those behaviors of a system
right those behaviors are um exactly uh
exactly you can say a bird's eye view
of the whole system or or its function
right or it could be in the form of
certain phenotype or physiological role
of that of that system so this
definition is given by near friedman he
is a
he is a computational scientist and also
a computational biologist um who who is
who is from
university of hebrew in jerusalem
right and he has been he works in the
area of uh of systems biology and also
machine learning approaches to study
gene regulation so he has given this uh
he has coined these uh definitions
though there are various definitions you
if you google uh
the term systems biology you'll get many
other definitions anyways uh so the
behavior of a system depends on on two
things right one is the properties of
the components uh the components of this
is uh properties of the components of
the system and the interactions between
those components components
so in molecular biology uh what we have
seen so far uh the whole approach is a
more of a reductionist approach and the
paradigm is shifting from that
reductionist approach to the
systems approach where we
haven't have it haven't uh have a idea
of
integrative uh
integrative biology or integrative uh
approach or specific interactions of
components in the biological systems are
studied like cells tissues organs
ecological web so there are various
hierarchies at which it can be studied
starting from the molecular or atomic
level
that is the cells tissues organs until
the ecological level so systems biology
can be studied at various levels right
so uh systems biology is a very uh
multidisciplinary field of science so
you all are aware of uh classical
bioinformatics which is always also
called as a multi dc which is always
been defined as a multidisciplinary
field of science similar resistance
systems biology is a very advanced uh
field or applicative field of
bioinformatics
so that definitely it is also a
multi-disciplinary
field of science right so
sorry so it is a multi-disciplinary uh
field of uh science
fine so uh
we have uh
we you can see in this slide that it is
it has biology
it has engineering sciences
bioinformatics
physics computer science mathematics all
are integrated together so biology
definitely because uh this is what is
the basis here right we are not anyway
studying any electrical system or or
electronic system or or or
any
any transport system right so we are
studying here biological system so
though the concepts are also been uh the
same concepts are also being used in uh
studying um studying other
non-biological systems also right or
models also but uh here uh
we uh the the basic problem is uh
problem or hypothesis or experiments are
definitely biological in nature so why
engineering science uh why engineering
science is a part of uh because uh the
like if you if you see classical
bioinformatics we don't see engineering
science concepts here but in systems
biology we see this uh engineering
science concepts here because we use uh
the concepts of networks we use the
concepts of control theory we use the
concepts of
system sciences uh even the uh systems
based uh systems based modeling and
simulation uh simulation concepts have
come from come from the engineering
sciences because you must have heard
that um
engineers design
cars design aeroplanes design
different electronic items uh even even
these uh
social networking sites like social like
they are also designed uh on the basis
of these network concepts right so so uh
so so all these concepts have come from
the engineering science concepts and now
through systems biology it has been used
in uh
by uh in biology right so and the uh one
of the
major or uh major
aspect in systems biology is networks uh
is uh
studying biology using networks right so
that is my main motto here to
tell you how networks can be used to
study um biological problems or to
understand biological problems then
bioinformatics because we use various
databases various uh as as
mr barwa has mentioned the the different
uh resources like um
like ncbi uniprot and stumble so all
these are various uh bioinformatics
resources right basic bioinformatics
resources so all those are also been
used in systems biology uh in some
way or the other
then we have uh computer science we use
various programming environments to do
modeling and simulation uh to create
more or to create networks or network
models so we use uh
we use standard we use gui gui based uh
tools and also we use uh programming
based uh tools and apps uh
right uh using uh using python uh
packages using our uh libraries or um
using matlab toolboxes right so that's
how computer science is a part of it as
well then physics definitely physics and
biology are in sim are inseparable field
of sciences so the
dynamics uh kinetics motions so all
these all these are uh physical aspects
that that are important part of biology
which are touched upon in systems
biology which are uh being used uh to to
model um in systems biology then
mathematics definitely no when we create
predictive models in systems biology uh
we use uh
different mathematical approaches like
using uh ordinary differential equations
using partial
differential equations odepd's
then
then
various probability based approaches uh
then
then
stoichiometries
matrices stoichiometries and anyways
matrices so matrices kinetic equations
so all these are
all these are mathematical problems and
they are being used here to uh to uh
solve problems in systems biology so i
hope you understood what uh what
is uh why systems biology is basically a
multi-disciplinary field of science now
next is uh
that in the important features of
systems biology so it has been um
responsible for some of the most
important developments in the science of
human
uh
health and environmental uh
sustainability so it is a holistic
approach to decipher bring the
complexity of biological uh systems that
starts um that starts from the
understanding that the networks that
form the whole of living organisms are
more than the sum of their parts right
so
it is collaborate so it is basically a
holistic approach right so we don't uh
study on the basis of one gene two genes
or three genes proteins one protein two
proteins no we use hundreds of genes
hundreds of proteins or probably the
whole system uh however uh what is the
however the uh
number of genes could be as many as uh
like you know
1000 10 000 um
in number or 30 000 in number so uh
their sizes are in terabytes anyways uh
so those are huge system huge number of
data in in that need that are uh
that are
that are part of those systems so uh
studying them together is a holistic
approach so systems biology is a
holistic approach it is collaborative in
nature so i have already mentioned
i have already explained why it is
collaborative in nature uh integrating
various uh field basic field of sciences
and then it is
its ability to design um its predictive
multiscale models so you can you can
design it at the molecular level atomic
level
then at the
tissue level cellular level organ level
organism levels we talk about various
organism level models where for example
the whole a whole organism
based metabolic models or genome scale
metabolic models of human genome scale
metabolic models of e coli saccharomyces
dairy bases or so in short we call them
as gems so that is at the organism level
even at the
at the population level the various
epidemiological models like for example
the best example the sir models
sir model is one of the examples right
uh so that can be that you know that
also comes under the basic area of basic
umbrella or the
overall umbrella of systems biology
right um so
so that's how it is uh multiscalar in
nature it enables our scientists to
discover new biomarkers for diseases
stratified patients based on unique
genetic profiles and target
identification for various uh
for drug designing purpose and other
treatments systems biology ultimately
creates the potential for entirely
new kinds of exploration and drives
constant innovation um innovation in
biology based technology and computation
right so these are some of the important
features of systems biology fine now
systems biology workflow how it it
actually um
how if but
a
particular research is taking place
using such this workflows right so
just one second
so you can see here the uh systems
biology workflow uh so this picture uh
depicts the general process of systems
biology you can or you can say the
workflow of systems biology it is an
iterative process so this is in cycle so
it is an iterative process uh which
begins with collecting and integrating
multiplex data so we start with
multi-omics data here from high
throughput experiments like uh how you
know about
big data in uh or large high throughput
data in
in in biology or
or biological sciences or biomedical
sciences right so those data
can be uh integrated uh the or
multi-omics
or those multi-omics data can be
integrated from high throughput
experiments uh it moves on to design and
build a model so we may build a model
here
this is called as model building right
uh so it has some resemblance with the
aiml based uh approaches but here the uh
uh
the approaches the various modeling
formalisms or techniques are little uh
are not little is is absolutely
different uh from uh from the algorithms
are different right so it is little
different from uh
from uh how we study uh
uh
the it uh from a from a data scientist
perspective data scientist perspective
so this is an engineering perspective of
our engineers perspective of uh of uh
studying uh or doing modeling or
simulations in system using systems
biology right so model building here uh
we do model building uh using uh various
bioinformatics and mathematical
approaches using computational and
simulation tools one can proceed to
analyze and interpret the data so this
is model analysis and interpretation so
from analysis and interpretation we come
up come out with hypothesis generation
then hypothesis uh testing so we do the
testing of the hypothesis and then so
see here modular a modeling and then
experimentation goes hand in hand so
it's not only solely um solely
computational in nature but we need
experimental data to uh validate it at
every steps right so it starts with
experimental data but in between um
in between there are various uh sections
where we also use experimental data to
keep on validating it so they so a
modeler and a or a systems biology star
and an experimental biologist work hand
in hand to
come up with a
with a model that represents the real
world system accurately right so what is
the what is the basic aim of modeling to
make some make a replica or to make a
to mimic the real world system so that
we can solve and we can do various
predictions we can solve various uh we
can understand various complex problems
uh through those models right so that is
the basic workflow of a systems biology
experiment
uh so next are key properties of
biological systems or models like uh
yes so every biological uh
systems or sorry every every biological
systems or models uh have certain
properties now these properties are
all quantifiable properties they are not
just english words uh that you are
seeing here that irreducibility emerges
complexity modularity so they all are
com quantifiable
properties and quantifiable uh
uh
aspects of uh of of any any any
biological system of any biological
system so when it's when i talk about
biological systems or just for your uh
for your understanding you can think
about any biological system starting
from a cell to protein complexes to cell
membrane then disease pathogenesis
uh
to uh for example cell cycle
transcription translation processes
right uh this is like no complex
diseases like neurodegenerative diseases
autoimmune disorders so anything can be
considered as a system but every system
has certain properties right which i'm
which i wanted to show you here in this
slide
where
irreducibility uh is the first property
where we may undoubtedly gain
significant insight into each of the
components of the system by studying
them individually but we need to under
study the system as a whole in order to
gain a holistic
perspective of what these components do
when they are all put together in an
appropriate manner so that's what is
irreducibility of a system for example
cellular respiration right so you can
give the example of a cellular
respiration then emergence
emergence is quite similar to
irreducibility but
it has a different ah it is a different
property where systems are composed of
different of individual elements or
parts that interact in various ways in
general the behavior of a system is
different quite different from merely
the sum of the functions of its various
parts this reinforces the need to
develop
methods to study biological systems at
the systems level rather than at the um
at the level of individual components
right so
next is complexity so complexity is
definitely a very important property of
biological systems so most of the
biological systems are very very complex
in nature so we are aim as a systems
biologist to target this complexity to
understand those complexity of
biological systems in certain quantities
or in certain quantifiable manner and
for example health and disease so health
and disease is
one of the best example of a complex
system for example cancer for example
diabetes so they are very complex
disorders right uh
and and uh and making a blueprint
blueprint of them that is making a model
of them is uh is again a very havoc task
and that's what we do in systems biology
this cannot be predicted simply by
analyzing the individual ligands or
proteins that comprise the cells a more
complete picture of their context would
be necessary to achieve it
biological systems are needless to say
that
they are extraordinarily complex as i
said and which is evident in individual
prokaryotic cells
not only in prokaryotic cells but also
in various multicellular organ
organisms right so
so for example uh the insulin
insulin production
for
insulin production
in diabetes or or or how insulin
production regulates uh regulates the
blood glucose level in a diabetic
patient so or probably how diabetes is
related to obesity or how diabetes is
related to cardiovascular disease so all
these are complex aspects and
that defines the complexity of a
biological system next is modularity so
what is modularity bacterial systems may
be viewed so modularity our
modules constitute semi-autonomous
entities right so every um
it's not that a a
a
particular biological process takes
place in in in a uniform or a
homogeneous system they have
heterogeneity
in the system uh which are called as
different modules or different clusters
um that uh work together uh to run that
system or to for the functioning of that
system so whenever i say system that
means biological system right so
so that's modularity is very important
and it can also be um it can also be
mathematically expressed so all these
properties can be mathematically
expressed
or has been already mathematically
expressed or defined right so
then robustness and fragility so
robustness and fragility uh is again a
very uh important uh property so there
are so much fluctuations um that happen
inside a cell uh i'm just giving an
example as cell as a system uh so uh
those perturbations are those
fluctuations that comes from the that
are inter intracellular and
extracellular fluctuations um in a in a
cell so that can be um
in spite of those fluctuations the
system
remains steady or remains
uh or maintains its
excuse me and maintains its uh
homeostasis uh so that is called as
robustness right and sensitivity and
fragility is that with the
simplest changes in
uh changes in uh in the concentrations
of certain uh certain metabolites or uh
or one point mutation or
or probably uh one small structural
change in an enzyme can cause a huge
difference in this whole system right
that can cause that cause a disease
excuse me
so that's what is uh robustness and
fragility
and robustness and fragility is one of
the another important aspect then there
is evolvability also uh evolvability of
systems so that is another property of
biological systems now networks uh let's
come to our uh main topic that is
network so systems biology is huge uh
right now there are many aspects of many
applications of systems biology
but
the one uh so systems biology has
modeling uh and simulation aspects also
but modeling and simulation of the whole
biological system not not just what what
you have studied probably in uh in drug
designing where we do molecular modeling
and drug designing this is not molecular
modeling this is this is whole cell
modeling this is whole system modeling
right we are modeling the whole system
we are not taking one module or two uh
one more one proteins or two proteins
probably and model them into uh so what
that is a different field of uh
bioinformatics all together that is drug
designing
and what that is called as cad that is
computer-aided drug designing right etc
now here we are uh we are all uh we are
all uh
trying to understand the uh the whole
system at a time right now
the one of the most important and uh one
of the most uh preliminary study that we
do uh in understanding the whole system
is through networks right so networks
are uh important aspect of uh studying a
biological system right uh so uh what
are networks right uh
what if someone asked you what are
networks a network of complex systems
can be mapped onto a graph in various
ways so networks are also called as
graphs right so they have all come from
the concept of engineering concept that
is graph theory right so we have so
networks are basically graphs in various
ways it it is possible to analyze all
paths between two nodes uh now
now every graph or
network can be defined as a set of nodes
or vertices and edges so that is nodes
and edges and edges describe a
relationship between the nodes uh so you
can see here uh
how betw how
these
nodes or the number of parts from a node
outside and the number of parts
terminating at a node are defined so
here you can see in the picture or the
diagram uh that's
below this
that's
at the bottom of this slide is here we
can see how nodes can be connected to
each other the figure on the right shows
um how a a affects how a
fx c
and
d also uh d but it itself uh but it
itself affected by b and d right uh
while b also uh affects d uh and c
has no connection with b or d
again uh
genes cells meta again abcd can be
what are these abcde right now this abcd
are basically the genes proteins
metabolites in a network right so i have
just simplified it or
generalized it into abc here so just for
your understanding
now uh
now uh
we have seen here about uh
uh uh like know what are networks
networks or nodes and networks are
basically representation with using
nodes and edges now we have various
parameters by which those networks can
be or network topology can be uh
parameterized or can be weighed right so
if somebody says that how good is your
network right you need to quantity you
need to tell that person that your
network is uh good on certain parameters
on the basis of certain parameters or on
the basis of certain values right so you
give those uh those
figures or those
numbers um that shows that your network
is actually quite appropriate and uh it
has meaning and you can and you can draw
inferences from it right network biology
so this this this particular topic is
called as network biology you must have
heard somewhere about this subject
called as network biology so this comes
under systems biology right where we
study uh system in the form of networks
so that is called as network biology
this is this is part of systems
biologists network biology and systems
biology are not same systems biology is
huge there are many many aspects of
systems biology we have systems
immunology we have systems microbiology
we have systems uh
systems uh biochemistry we have uh right
so there are systems biology can be
applied to uh any biological field of
sciences but uh
network biology is more or less
concentra even in systems biology we
study uh models predictive models right
uh we do predictions uh using models and
making a model is not an easy task right
so
so networks are uh just network
represents and it's quite interesting to
get um get inferences from or get uh
insights through these networks so
network biology provides a quantifiable
uh description of networks there are
several network measures that enable the
comparison and uh and and
characterization of
complex uh networks now first one is
connectivity or degree we call how how
well they are connected how how well and
it it's not just connecting connecting
the dots it it's uh every connection and
every um every
dots uh how they are how they are placed
in the network has a meaning it's not
just connecting the dots you think that
network biology is just going to the
string database or epic database or
probably going to cytoscape and join
those doors it's nothing it's not not as
simple as that there are various deeper
in aspects of of networks uh where we
understand networks where we infer from
networks about various uh various uh
understanding of the of those biological
processes right connectivity first is
connectivity now what is connectivity so
here k represents connectivity is
represented by k or degrees the connect
degree of connectivity is represented by
k uh so their k represents the number of
uh links the node has to other nodes in
the network for example uh for directed
net so we have two types like directed
and undirected networks so for directed
networks k has two components k in and k
out there are various arrows that are
going out and there are various arrows
which are coming in so everything has a
meaning so they are not uh like no
not just uh web webs or for uh
complicated pictures uh but
they have meaning uh inside them uh or
encrypted in them uh in networks so the
in degree so this k in is in degree and
k out is out degree num uh right so they
can be um
they can be uh they can be quantified or
they can be uh parameterized uh
by using uh softwares like cytoscape you
cytoscape has various features by which
you can
measure this measure these parameters
right then degree distribution um degree
distribution is represented by pk is
obtained by counting the number of nodes
uh with k like one two links and uh one
comma two
number of links one and
dividing by the number of nodes uh to
distinguish between the various network
topologies then clustering coefficient
is another um another important
parameter of uh studying the um
the quality of a network where the
average clustering coefficient
characterizes the overall tendency of
nodes to form uh clusters of groups
which is represented by ck ck is defined
as the average average clustering uh
clustering
clustering coefficients for all nodes
with k links
so
it is also called as
we have clicks diagnose certain clicks
or we have certain hubs so they have
different meanings in network biology
clicks hubs uh
modules uh or sub graphs so they have
different meanings right um so
characteristics of path length so when
we uh when we when when we have two
nodes there is a path between those two
nodes it measures the typical uh
separation between two vertices in the
network uh intuitively it uh represents
the network's overall navigability right
now how the network is actually
navigating from one node to the other
node so the whole navigability can um
can be represented by the path lengths
then we have network diameters there are
huge number of parameters we have a book
totally a book by barabasi uh
bushnan barabasi and bushnan
albert barabasi and bushnan
where he has explained so many type of
properties of our network parameters and
every parameter gives you different
meanings different inferences which you
cannot solve at the
molecular level or at the singular level
we you can only solve it at the system
level when you have everything in front
of you all the genes all the proteins
all the metabolites in front of you and
you can uh infer from them right from
their connectivities so uh
so that's all about uh network diameter
so there is a network diameter as well
uh where uh the network diameter is the
greatest distance between two nodes in
the network fine
now uh
let's move ahead so we have on the basis
of uh these nodes and edges and the
parameters we have various types of
biological networks we have different
types of biological networks now
biological networks uh could be many
types right uh networks have no limits
now you can you can make disease
networks you can make disease gene
networks you can make drug
net
drug gene protein networks you can make
uh
so there are various type of bipartite
networks or graphs uh that you can make
so for better understanding you should
always start with understanding the
intracellular networks right the
intracellular networks are more uh
more
easier to start with
so for example metabolic networks we
have gene regulatory networks signal
transduction or cell signaling networks
protein protein interaction networks
right etc so these are uh these are uh
the intracellular networks these are
also intracellular networks but they
don't come under any particular category
uh so they are very specific like for
example immune network or immunological
networks depending on all the immuno
immunological aspects you can make
networks then there are drug target
interaction networks or dtis we call
them as dtis and this particular field
is called as network medicine these days
these days there is a
field of science called as network
medicine or uh network pharmacology so
all these comes all these counts the um
drug target interaction networks fine um
right uh so next uh
um
now
whenever we make a network uh in any
platform in uh in any tool or in any uh
in any uh platform like for example in
cytoscape or in cell designer you make a
network right or
right so those networks are represented
in certain formats right so there are
file formats for networks also or models
also systems biology models also
networks and models are different things
right uh
models are predictive in nature networks
are not predictive in nature they cannot
predict anything they only give you
inferences and they only give you
insights about the various interactions
right so systems biology have various uh
uh various formats uh like for one of
like the one of the format that one of
the very widely used format is called as
sbml format that is systems biology
markup language it's an xml based format
and
that is extensible markup language based
format and
a representation format it is a
representation format for communicating
and storing computational models of
biological process even the networks can
also be represented in spml format then
they are free and open standards with
widespread software support they can
represent many different classes of
biological phenomena including metabolic
networks cell signaling so all those
intracellular types of networks can be
represented using sbml file format now
next is another type of file format is
there which is quite widely used for
cell based networks like whole cell
networks so we can make global networks
of the whole cell the whole cell where
the various intracellular
networks are integrated among themselves
like the cell signaling the
metabolic networks uh cell signaling
networks gene regulatory networks all
are integrated among themselves and make
the uh whole setup of the cell network
so the it is represented in another
format called as cell ml format which is
again in um again an xml based uh format
and uh
and it has uh it describe also describes
mathematical models similar to it is
similar to html format but it provides
greater scope of the model modularity
and reusability and it is not specific
to descriptors of biochemistry
any anyone can submit reviews update
models and receive feedbacks and help
from the community of cell ml a cell ml
discussion um so uh several other
formats are also available other than
cell ml like mathml is there then
biopacks format is there so there are
different other types of formats by
which systems biology or network biology
based uh models and networks can be
represented and used in different
softwares uh for various analysis and
for various uh inference um
inferences or insights uh getting
inferences and insights now these are
systems biology databases uh that we use
quite uh
frequently quite widely first one is get
database it is a collection of uh
database with genomes biological
pathways so it is not a pathway database
it's a very comprehensive database this
get database it has it has checked genes
get proteins keg
drugs right now so it has it is a very
comprehensive database like ncbi so keg
is not uh it is a myth that keg is
considered as only a pathway database
not it is not correct keg also has
various uh informations or various
annotations of various genes proteins uh
like my single molecules also that is
single biomolecules also fine so then we
have biomodels biomodels is especially a
a free and open source repository for
storing exchanging and retrieving
quantitative models so it is the only
one of the
one of the sole uh database which
contains uh biomodels we have um during
my phd i created a uh created a model uh
of uh
model that that depicts the um depicts
the energy pool where we i have actually
integrated all the anabolic and
catabolic
pathways in human
right and made a model uh
for various predictions uh you uh under
different conditions like
like disease conditions healthy
conditions
fasting condition diabetic condition
different metabolic disorder conditions
so i have tested my model and it has
given exactly same results as as in the
experiment so my model has been
submitted and accepted by biomodels it
is available if any one of you wanted to
use it um in case you are interested in
that area definitely uh you can use it
right so
next is big big database big databases
big database so big databases
is
is the
database for
for biochemistry genes and genomes
so it contains
various genome scale models mostly the
models that have been created by
constraint based modeling uh constraint
based modeling and kinetic modeling uh
so those models mostly constraint based
modeling
where we generate genome scale or genome
genomics based uh metabolic models uh
model reconstructions or genome-based
model reconstructions can be found in
big database it has it covers
the gems we call them as gems that is
genome scale metabolic models you call
also call them as gsms that is genome
scale metabolic models uh you get
uh you get more than uh like you know uh
more than 50 more 50 models that are
present for various trains or various
organisms and also human also the whole
gem of human has been is is uh
you can find in big database
right then we have uh react home
database which is a free online database
for biological pathways rectum is also
by uh so okay biomodels is biomodels is
a database
for uh by
embl ebi similarly bio psych is also
sorry reactom is also a database by uh
by embl ebi uh in collaboration with
some other uh organizations in europe
and uh react database is quite opposite
to uh bio models it has only the pathway
information but it is very very
attractive uh reactant database so you
get
you get informations like google maps
like you keep on uh you you take a
pathway you get you take a network you
you keep on scrolling it and
you keep on zooming it out and you keep
on entering into the intricacies of that
of that network uh into the metabolites
into the various genes that it encodes
for so it's very interesting to explore
react from database then we have biocide
database metasite database then for for
protein protein interactions um we have
epi database that is agile protein
interaction data analyzer um so
it is uh mostly you must have heard
about string database so string is not
the only database that you can use for
protein protein interactions you also
can use epic database app it is also uh
quite a useful database as string
probably you may not find something in
string you can search it in epit
database also right so they are used uh
they both are used for uh protein
protein interactions
now we have various tools here uh which
are quite widely used if you are not
comfortable with programming languages
uh you can use these gui based tools
like they are they they are they are
used quite uh
quite uh
widely um and they are very
authenticated you can publish papers by
doing some good work using cell designer
copaci
uh or cytoscape you are aware of
cytoscape i think so and uh
you can make models in cell designer you
can
do simulations modeling and simulations
in copac
and uh
definitely you know about cytoscape for
visualization of complex networks and
integrating the various uh gene
expression or various expression data or
high throughput data with those type of
with any type of attribute data right so
they are all open source uh databases
other than that that you can use the
various toolboxes in matlab you can use
various packages in
various packages in
in
python you can use with systems based
systems biology or network biology based
path
model making uh packages are there then
you can use in our programming language
also various uh various libraries and
packages find next
we have these types of systems biology
networks and models we have four major
types of networks models that can be
built based on the research needs and
the
the data in hand and the state of a
system the state of a system is a
snapshot of the system at a given time
that contains uh
that contains enough information to
predict the behavior of the system for
all future times so we have these four
uh types uh deterministic uh that the
future state of the process may be
determined by the current state which
uses the ordinary differential equation
based or pd based methods stochastic
which uh future state cannot be
determined only a probability can be
predicted so where there are random
variables too many random variables that
can be uh done in uh done using
stochastic methods we have continuous uh
methods that is called as uh the values
of the states are continuous where the
values of the states uh different states
of the uh of the components are
continuous then we have discrete uh the
values of the states are discrete that
is not continuous where we use this
boolean boolean modeling or
boolean modeling methods right
or logic based modeling methods
now
uh model uh network uh
model development and construction so
this is the whole process first of all
formulation uh of the problem
formulation of the problem definitely so
this you just uh
understand this process uh this is like
a
flow chart or you can say uh these steps
formulation of the problem first of all
you need to ask the question that you
are
you wanted to
define you wanted to work on whether you
wanted to identify biomarkers whether
you are going for drug target
identification you are going for
uh optimizing certain metabolites in
biomed by metabolic engineering for
which are used for uh various uh
various product uh
bioproduct formation uh
optimization so these are various
problems that you are so you need to
first identify your problem then
verification uh of the available
information so how much information is
available for your support as a
supporting data for you then selection
of the model structure uh determine the
general type of model like for example
deterministic or stochastic approach
that you are going to use which type of
method that you that is suitable for
your fault for modeling or for
network-based modeling then establishing
a simple model a model can be built
through mathematical formulation then
sensitivity analysis for validation
mathematical simulation may be highly
sensitive to parameter changes that
means in sensitivity analysis we change
certain parameters and see how it
affects the system and whatever whatever
is the effect in the system that that
needs to be validated or cross checked
with the experimental data right so
experimental tests then we can uh use
experimental tests of the model
prediction so we need some wet lab
validation sometimes or or probably if
you have a paper or literature already
been done uh or experiments already been
done you can compare it can compare with
that and see whether your model is
acting um as
as
real as possible or not right uh so then
the stating the agreements and
divergences between the experimental and
modeling uh whether the model results
agree with the experimental behavior if
results do not agree check the faults
check check for false assumptions right
over simplifications of the model wrong
model structure inadequate uh
experimental data or other inadequately
represented factors so all this will
check that whether what is the issue
with your model that is not giving or
it's not getting validated with the
experimental data iterative refinement
of the model refinement of model is also
very important because
um the more you refine the model the
more you uh
fill up the gaps that are present in the
model the more accurate uh it gets right
or it gives you the answer the
perturbation of a uh to a network model
so perturbation means the changes that
we do to a model the networks of
different topologies uh
very uh vary in their resilience to
various types of uh various types of
perturbations the process starts with
systematic perturbation of biological
systems monitoring uh the pathway
responses
the integration of the data formulation
of mathematical models that describe the
structure of the system and its response
to perturbation so perturbation analysis
is very important where we for example
you knock out certain genes you knock
knock in certain genes or probably you
have
you have
just uh stopped certain pathways in a
metabolic model or in a biochemical
biochemical network model and you see
what changes it goes
happens if there is no change that means
those pathways are not very important
for the for the for that particular for
that particular problem right so or uh
right so this this perturbation analysis
is very important even you can change
the concentrations you can change the
expression values of various genes and
proteins and see what happens to the
model how how the model behaves right so
that is uh
that is a very regular thing that we do
in systems biology then applications of
biological network models are manifold
um right so you can use it in the whole
biology
any any field of biological sciences
starting from uh starting from
the
bio process technology or metabolic
engineering then in medical uh
biomedical sciences where you can use uh
our biomedical applications like uh
network-based drug discovery discovering
complex relate sorry personalized and
precision medicine right um so these can
be done using aiml also but uh this can
be done using systems biology approaches
also so the choice is yours um right um
we do it in two ways it's i always say
that uh data uh science in biology
always gives rise to two directions one
is aiml based approaches and another one
is systems biology based approaches so
i'm talking all about systems biology
approaches today like so plant and
microbial metabolic engineering
personalized and precision medicine
network-based drug discovery uh
discovering complex relations etc
now network in france to us to
understand disease pathogenesis so this
is the case study or this is the um
you can say the research topic that we
are going to
uh
understand today this is one of the
applications that i have chosen because
i have worked a lot on understanding
disease pathogenesis uh using network in
france all right uh so systems uh
biology and used to decipher uh
decipher uh these multicell
multiscaler uh
the pathogenesis of uh
the most of
the pathogenesis one second
this i cannot see the slide
the pathogenesis of most multi-genetic
diseases involves interactions and
feedback loops uh across multiple
temporal and spatial scales from
cellular to organism level so the
robust uh
characteristic of the network uh the
robust characteristic of the network uh
is uh traded off due to impact of
perturbations on the native network
leading to changes in the phenotypic
responses thereby exhibiting disease
states
right uh next is clearly this network
inferences uh clearly the system level
uh
study uh is required to reveal the
fundamental principles of disease
initiation and progress uh possible to
understand the dynamics of these
networks using the disease model so you
can see here the examples of disease
pathogenesis
disease pathogenesis networks
so
the first example that i can give here
is uh cancer network so a signaling
network of a signaling uh network uh of
uh
remarkable complexity that is of
critical importance to cancer tumor so
this is the paper that has been
published so i have taken this picture
from that paper this is published in
2000 in cell
where they have shown the complexity of
the cancer cell network right so this is
not a network diagram actually this is
just a book diagram or you can say
literature based diagram uh right so
this is again a literature based diagram
this is not a network diagram so you can
make a network out of this
out of this uh
from this
keeping this diagram as a as a base uh
based network then uh next next example
is that where you can study disease
pathogenesis network is diabetes type
two it has already been published uh the
diabetes type two model it's a
systems-based or network-based model uh
where you can see the various biological
these various nodes are actually denotes
the um you know the biological processes
protein abundance cell secretion the
various activities actually uh not the
genes and proteins the various
activities has been represented by by
these various nodes and edges
right
the nodes nodes but edges are
edges are actually here shows the either
it is increasing the activity or
decreasing the activity or directly
increasing the activity indirectly
increasing the activity directly
decreasing the activity so all these
connectivities
can be explained so this is basically
understanding the whole diabetic process
uh or uh
or type 2 diabetes uh model
understanding diabetes model so this is
the
work that we have done in our lab uh
where uh where we have made a uh
where we have worked on the network
inferences and also drug target
identifications using networks uh in
vitiligo or we call it as vitiligo uh
and autoimmune disorder it's a it's a
it's a chronic uh uh it's an autoimmune
disorder skin disease where where the
the hyperactive
immune system
kills its own
melanin cells or melanocytes right uh
from the basal layer of the epidermis
epidermis which leads to patchy uh loss
of skin color right which is quite uh
quite uh related to psoriasis and um
also i we have also done some work where
we have done the correlational networks
correlational networks between vitiligo
and
multiple sclerosis and
then
rheumatoid arthritis and
rheumatoid arthritis and psoriasis uh
etc and also we are working on
connecting it to other diseases like uh
like uh
uh
thyroid hyperthyroid hyperthyroidism and
then
and then
um
diabetes etc so we are trying to do this
correlational network analysis between
uh between uh the because this type of
analysis gives you an idea that this
this type of complex diseases are not uh
not uh caused by one factor they are
multifactorial diseases right uh
so we have developed along with that
also we have developed this uh
database which uh has been published in
two of the journals um vitiligo uh
information uh resource uh vitiligo
information resource that is uh
v db we call it as very db here and uh
so so this is the whole structure or
features of the vrdb database uh where
we have differential genes interest
intersecting genes natural leads of lead
compounds so we have done some docking
studies also this is just for this
database we have done though this is not
our main area um so we have done some
network uh studies and we have shown
them in the network gallery uh where we
have shown differential g networks
intersection networks with multi
multiple sclerosis intersection networks
with psoriasis uh intersection network
with rheumatoid arthritis dark target
protein
networks and also uh we have done some
uh
uh vt lego information resource profiles
like kdb connectivity pdb db
connectivity string db connectivity etc
right so we have used mostly uh
microarray data here uh for the gene
network and uh
to uh we have analyzed those microarray
data and uh
done this uh analysis and then this
network studies uh we are still working
a lot on different aspects of uh
vitiligo information resources it has
more other informations i would like all
of you to visit that website this is
called as www
so you can get to know our database more
and we have more uh such uh network
based analysis and also some some sort
of drug target identification analysis
and we have published them in prg and uh
uh and f thousand research uh recently
so these are some of the features uh
like uh ppi networks ggi networks type
gene interaction networks protocol
interaction networks etc now uh we have
come almost to the end of the
uh
almost to the end of this talk uh that
what is the take home message that we
can do from here
that in recent years systems biology
approaches and more specifically uh
network-based approaches emerged as
powerful tools for studying complex
diseases these approaches are often
built uh are often built on the
knowledge of uh physical
uh or functional interactions between
molecules which are usually represented
as an interaction network a variety of
intermolecular interactions including
protein protein interactions protein dna
interactions and rna interactions are
essential to these cooperative uh
activities these interactions can be
conveniently represented as networks
with nodes with the networks that is
graphs with nodes and which denote
molecules or the components and the
links which denote the interactions
between them network biology provides a
powerful tool it is a part of systems
biology but it is it provides a powerful
tool for the study or an elegant way of
studying the complex diseases or complex
problems since uh in biological sciences
or biomedical sciences network based
approaches leverage the idea that
complex diseases can be better
understood uh from the perspective of
disregulated molecules than at the
individual gene level so
uh i guess i'm almost
at the end of uh my talk
uh now
just uh one slide that shows my group my
research group
at amit university noida
in india and we have this
website if anybody is interested you can
visit this website and see our different
researches and different papers and book
chapters and various aspects and various
projects we are already running
a dbt funded project
we have people from here uh
who has got dst sub young scientist
awards welcome trust genome campus they
have uh they have been uh like no uh got
fellowships for uh attending various
workshops at welcome trust uh genome
campus in the mbl ebi
even i have also gone there for uh
training and because mine as my model
was accepted by bio models in embl ebi
campus so i was selected there so
ongoing funded project we have ai base
we also work on ai nml uh based
approaches also for various uh omics or
for various big data in biology for
analyzing them
all right so what we do we do genome
scale model reconstructions we do
constraint based modeling flux analysis
clinical data analytics and association
studies discovering biomarkers and
generating machine learning models that
we do uh separately that is basically
being headed by dr priyanka narada he
she is also uh
the another uh coin investigator in our
lab and along with me um
she is also the mentor here uh multi
multiomics integration with genome scale
metabolic model so this is
this is purely systems biology
multi-level biological network modeling
and analysis so these are our
project associates phd scholars and
research associates etc so
thank you all uh for uh listening to me
and i could uh i hopefully i could
cover
uh
as much as i could
in systems biology and network
inferences and how network biology can
be used in solving
various biological problems
thank you so much dr sengupta
yeah thank you
thank you very much sir
it was amazing to
get to know so much of from you the talk
was really insightful
and
we explored a lot of applications about
systems biology and network analysis
well uh we have a few questions in the
chat from our audience so i will take up
some of them um
this question is from auschwitz she asks
can the system's biology approach be
used to understand the immune system of
an organism
and are the similar databases used in
the process like the ones used for drug
discovery
yes definitely uh presently we are
working on similarly as exactly for
vitiligo so since vitiligo is a
autoimmune disorder uh we have not
worked on the immunological networks we
can work on immunological and this is
quite new uh for making immunological
networks rather than going into gene
regulatory networks or
protein networks we can we can
specifically focus on immunological
networks uh for uh and mostly for
immunological networks we use uh
mathematical modeling or differential
equation based uh modeling approaches
uh insist from systems biology for model
to model them and
the databases that we use for drug
discovery are different from the
databases we use in systems biology we
can yes definitely uh take the if you
are going for drug target interaction or
drug target interaction networks then
definitely you need to use those
drug-based drug
databases uh or probably uh
the various uh databases that we use for
uh for getting the drug molecules and do
some
do some initial level docking studies to
uh to just cross check them right uh so
those things can be
done at that level but uh definitely not
for pure systems biology we don't use
drug discovery based databases that are
specifically for drug discovery
okay thank you so much dr gupta here's
one more question from sanju vikka sini
and
the question is what are the
applications of systems biology in
industries we
learned about the research application
but what
like what are the sectors in which the
industries might benefit from systems
biology oh okay so uh in industry first
of all the industry that i will tell uh
uh is uh
is uh this um
uh the the antibiotic based industry or
uh the uh various uh secondary
metabolites or
various plant-based metabolites based uh
based industry where we do uh where we
actually optimize the production of
various metabolites
from
from smaller organisms because those
organisms from where we get good
metabolites are probably the secondary
metabolites uh are are very minuscule so
uh we use uh model organisms like e coli
or saccharomyces cerevisiae to to
optimize their production and that can
be done and that can be taken to the
industry for example you must have heard
about
uh
the companies like genometica in
in us or uh
like so those those companies uh those
companies uh use uh use systems biology
and synthetic biology approaches for uh
for higher production of uh various
useful bio products like those are
produced in the cell factory right um so
this is one of the application and
another application in uh health and
diseases identification of drug targets
identification of biomarkers uh it helps
in drug discovery like no drug in drug
discovery we used to uh take one
molecule two molecules three molecules
at a time but now using this uh systems
biology approaches we can i we can work
with multiple number of drug targets at
a time
so that is that actually uh aggravates
the or uh the importance or significance
of or the more productivity of um
research in drug designing right or
drug discovery
so these are some some there are many
other uh we can make models which
we can make various models which can be
used by the various uh healthcare
sectors or experimentalists to validate
their data so those models can also be
used as um as uh
as a as a as a
model system right because there are
various ethical issues by for using
human for example human gem right as i
have mentioned genome scale model in
human so you cannot use human for uh for
human samples for every uh experiments
uh there are various ethical issues
related to it so instead of that if you
can use the human uh genome scale model
or whole human genome skill model uh
like whole human genome you can use
whole human genome skill metabolic model
uh for for for various studies for
example if you wanted to study study a
particular type of cancer you can take
the whole genome scale model of human
and study that particular aspect of
cancer uh in
in using that those models those systems
management there are many other
applications i have mentioned few of
them
right thank you so much dr sengupta and
in continuation to the answer that you
already gave right now there's another
question so john wants to know that can
we apply systems biology in organ on a
chip model so that's again a substitute
for testing anything on a live organism
yes yes organ on a cheap model but uh we
use spatial based modeling so uh i have
never worked on that but yes definitely
uh we can use uh
see uh there is a project called as uh
physio human physium project that is
being that is an ongoing project where
they generate these virtual organ models
organ-based models they generate
musculoskeletal models they generate
pancreatic models that they have they
have generated this uh big heart models
then pancreas so all those models can be
generated uh computationally but then
they have to take it to the organ on a
chip
they can translate it to the organ on a
chip
system
all right thank you so much dr sanjup
and here's the final question from my
end so i had this question in my mind
you talked about various modeling and
simulation tools what's the
computational power required to run
those softwares
it does not require very high and
systems you can use it in your simple
laptop also the only problem is with the
data suppose that i think you are also
aware of if you are using rna data or
probably if you are using ngs whole
genome sequence data then definitely you
need uh
the more computational uh power like for
your system for processing those data
then we can enter into comp systems
biology that does not require much
computational uh power but yes for like
matlab based uh which is actually a uh
paid software matlab and it's a heavy
software uh for that probably you may
need little bit better systems but
otherwise even even a even in a simple
laptop you can make models
but yes
for the initial data processing you need
computational space and power
right i get it well thank you so much dr
sengupta it was a pleasure to have you
as a guest today and we learned about so
many things i'm sure the audience got
many messages to take home from today's
webinar it was insightful for all of us
thank you so much for your time
thank you thank you
mr barua
all right thank you so much everyone for
joining in and before we wrap up today's
great webinar i have a few things to
share with you which
might you might be interested in some of
the more opportunities coming up and
some other ways in which you can benefit
your
thoughts for learning
so adding on to
data science and
programs on data science we as i
mentioned in the beginning at omix logic
we also have some modules and training
in collaboration with very many of
universities and organizations
where we talk about
uh the data science concept and how we
can apply it into bioinformatics so i
will quickly walk you through the
various programs and training
opportunities that we have at tommy's
logic find biotech and all of these
learning training modules are held
synchronously as well as asynchronously
that is live as well as pre-recorded it
is live through interactive zoom
sessions there are various self-guided
study materials already uploaded on our
learn omix logitech platform as well as
practical hands-on assignments on the t
bio info platform and the amis logic
code playground which i will be touching
upon really shortly
this is a snippet of the
way in which we have integrated the
coding console onto our platform but you
don't need to download any extra
ide or a software to run
codes like python or r which you can
directly do it right over here and
generate various meaningful biological
results
now how to do that has been
comprehensively mentioned in the various
courses where we have
courses like genomics
python for bioinformatics art for
informatics and more
these courses introduce you to the
concepts of data science in biological
sciences
biomachine learning course introduces
the logic behind machine learning what
are the various types of machine
learning tools and algorithms that can
be used
including
a tutorial on how to use excel python r
studio as well as the t bioinfo platform
you can also go beyond these resources
and write your own codes in a much more
limitless way using jupyter notebook or
google collab and github
through these programs we help students
understand the concepts behind
unsupervised machine learning various
clustering methods supervised machine
learning feature selection
and regression models deep learning
and network analysis and also combining
various strategies
for machine learning
in general
we also
have a special design of delivering
training programs which includes
hands-on aspect as well as project-based
learning
learning only makes sense when you are
able to apply it in a practical way and
therefore
omics logic trainings are different than
others because it incorporates various
projects examples which are taken from
published research papers which are
publicly available their public data
sets and
goes through a tutorial which is
designed in such a way that you will
walk the steps in which a scientist or a
researcher did or perform their own
analysis in this way you will get a
sense of how to define a research
question what are the various methods
and techniques to apply to generate
meaningful results and finally how to
draw a biologically significant
conclusion from the
results that you have generated from
these
tools
i i will quickly go over the t by info
platform because as we all know
biologists are not very good coders
i mean that's kind of a usual
understanding well many people are
expert in coding nowadays
so
if you are not an expert in coding that
doesn't mean the end of the world
because at find biotech economics logic
we have a comprehensive point-and-click
ai enabled cloud-based platform where
you don't need to write even a single
line of code and what you can basically
do is just with a click of one pointer
you can get your entire analysis done so
this is how the tbi info platform looks
like and just by clicking and joining
the various tools which are mentioned
here from the various boxes you create a
pipeline through which you can generate
results from your high throughput data
sets and then take it forward to analyze
the tibia info platform also generates
publication worthy graphics and images
and figures which you can
incorporate into your
research paper publication or any
posters
the t by info serves various purposes
which includes the sequencing seq domain
about various machine learning tools
such as unsupervised supervised and more
and variant calling structure analysis
phylogenetics and a lot more than that
so here's again talking about how these
homologic courses not only teaches you
to understand the logic behind
bioinformatics but also teaches you to
be to get
expertized with python and r so these
are some of the courses that we already
have in our on our platform which you
can complete at your own pace whenever
you want
so
python are and
finally you can
you can translate your understanding and
your knowledge to basic and
translational research projects that you
can do
so the entire story winds up
like this at omix logic you get training
you learn some concepts you learn some
skills then you apply it in your own
project and
you can be
someone who can benefit from our ongoing
research fellowship program which is
equivalent to the internship programs
that you have all across the world
by completing the fellowship program you
will be able to design your own research
project with the help of mental guidance
and find biotech so here's an example of
a project completed by a student from
amsterdam university noida
her name is vedic and she
did her project in the transcriptomics
of kovid19 which is now published on our
platform
as dr sengupta also mentioned we have a
huge collaboration between find biotech
and amity university and as a result of
this collaboration especially with them
at university noida campus we bring
various exciting opportunities for the
students of empty university
such as industry academic internships
and more
so
apart from the already uploaded
asynchronous courses that we have on the
tbi on the omixlogic learn platform we
also have various programs which are
launched time to time in these programs
you will get
training from our mentors who will
give you their insights into some
specialistic aspect of various
applications of bioinformatics for
example right now we are running a
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
program where you will learn about how
you can apply bioinformatics for
research in the field of infectious
diseases specifically taking the
examples of covid19 ebola malaria and
tuberculosis
in the future we will also be having
specialized courses on precision
oncology where we will be talking about
cancer research in more depth
for anybody who is looking to start with
a journey in bioinformatics you are most
welcome to check out our introduction to
bioinformatics program which introduces
you to the various concepts of
bioinformatics we also have programs
dedicated to genomics and genomics in
the virtual lab
we also will be having specialized
programs on transcriptomics
and data science for
biomedical data analysis such as the one
that in which we will be talking about
all the concepts that we were discussing
today
we also have a major collaboration with
the federation of asian biotechnology
association or faba and as a result of
this collaboration we will be coming up
with various exciting opportunities for
the students in india and asia as a
result of the
huge network of industries that faba is
associated with
talking about our international
collaborations we also have a massive
collaboration with the louisiana's
biomedical research network and
louisiana state university where we are
providing courses and training programs
for the students who are a part of this
institution
talking about the national association
of idea principle investigators
also known as nepi we are providing free
bioinformatics education to 23 states in
the united states of america and puerto
rico and as a result of this
major collaboration many students in the
united states of america are benefiting
in the domain of mathematics education
research and training
so
it's a good opportunity for requesting
all of you to get stay in touch with us
we are available on all the social media
handles please find us and stay in touch
with us to get notified about any
upcoming opportunity where you can take
part and benefit from
a quick reminder about psionic so we
were having various topics throughout
the very many months and in february we
had bioinformatics and data science we
will be having many more sessions coming
up in the next weeks
and in march
specifically on 31st march and first
difference we will be having a huge
international conference which is known
as the omix research symposium this is a
great opportunity for all of you to take
part in in this
symposium we will be having
special guest
speakers from all around the world from
various academic partners from various
universities from various industries and
also research labs who will be sharing
their research and progresses made all
throughout the past year and the
applications in bioinformatics
leveraging it for
performing cutting-edge research we will
be also having various exciting
opportunities for students namely the
post representation competition where
you will be given the opportunity to
submit your own research as an as a
poster these posters will be evaluated
by our judges and you will be getting
prizes at the end of the poster
presentation competition
more information about the symposium the
poster conference and the panel of
speakers and the dates and times will be
available on our social media handles as
well as on your email so keep an eye on
all of those channels and platforms
finally it's a request to all of you
present here to kindly scan or
copy the link and give us a feedback of
how your experience was in this
particular webinar your feedback is
important for us because it helps us
provide you quality
learning experience in a very smooth and
seamless way
so here's a heads up for all of you
and coming up then in the next psionics
session we will be having dr ersk
kassoek as our guest speaker she is an
assistant director at the louisiana
state university chevape and she will be
talking about bioinformatics and data
science training and how she and her
group is revolutionizing the way in
which bioinformatics is provided to the
students and how students from any
background can learn and apply
bioinformatics in their research so this
webinar will be held on february 11 2022
at 3 p.m central standard time
and on february 18th we will be having
dr mohit mason who is a business
development director and project mentor
at find biotech and he will be talking
about structural biology
this research aspect as well as how you
should design your research project and
your abstract this is in lieu with the
poster presentation competition so i
encourage all of you to take part in it
and attend these sessions so that you
can get the insights from our experts
about what's the best way to design your
abstract what's the best way to design
your project and that would help you be
in a better position to
be awarded the winner of this poster
presentation competition
having said that we are now at the end
of today's
um webinar session i will take up all
the questions that you have in the chat
feel free to use the chat section to
post more questions i will be
definitely answering all of you so about
the recording of today's session you
will be definitely getting the recording
through your emails please keep an eye
on that
and also on our social media handles we
will be posting the links to the
recordings
talking about the training in africa and
nigeria we do have various training
programs that are running in africa we
have our team
of amex logic
at africa who are based in africa who
are providing quality training and
education so if you're interested in
learning more about those trainings and
how to connect to the group please send
an email to us at marketing at the
ratebind.bio
i will put it in the chat
or you can also send it to
communications at the redfinder.bio
and we will provide you with further
information regarding
the training in
nigeria i will share the
link of the feedback form
with you so that you can
go over with it just give me a moment
um okay so the whatsapp group was full i
will check it and i will send you for
the links
regarding the
whatsapp links and i will tell you about
the poster presentation session in just
a minute just give me one moment i will
share my screen and
i will show you what the poster
presentation
session looks like
so
while i am doing that the poster
presentation session basically is
for students who are doing your own
research or you want to do a research
you are welcome to submit your abstracts
for now
and once you share our submitter
abstracts the deadline is 28th of
february
once you submit your abstract with us we
will be doing a
screening of those abstracts to identify
the best ones
and once we have identified them we will
definitely
contact you regarding the guidelines for
sharing your poster
and
i am re-sharing my screen to enable you
the post representations
link
so this is the page for poster
presentation i'm also putting it down in
the chat so that you can also visit it
so
the poster presentation
for the mixed logic research symposium
covers these following topics
omix and bioinformatics
obviously applied in research
you might have done it as an independent
project or a project with your
university professors or your summer
internship somewhere you are welcome to
submit such projects
if it is in the domain of ai and machine
learning and data science that is the
application of data science ai level
into
bioinformatics and biological science
we are also interested in welcoming
abstracts in the domain of astrobiology
and spaceomics that is a new and
exciting domain because we will be
having a separate panel in the symposium
dedicated to astrobiology and specimens
and various great speakers from
from the most famous organizations in
space sciences and astrobiology will be
coming
in this symposium so it's a great
opportunity to
give exposure to your research and
interest in front of those experts and
finally if you're researching in the
domain of computational biology and
biotech and pharma you're also welcome
to submit your
abstracts here
now here's a quick guideline for the
abstracts
so the abstract length can be from 150
to 200 words you can you should divide
it into various segments such as
objective methods results and conclusion
the font should be in monsterat and 12
points and it must be a pdf file so you
have to convert it into a pdf file and
submit it using this particular form
right here just go down you will get an
option to choose your file and submit
your
abstract here the deadline is 28
february so keep that in mind here are
the three prizes that you are
that you can win the best poster
presentation the best citizen science
project and young sheldon award for high
school students who are doing
cutting-edge research
in the domain of bioinformatics so
that's all that i have to share about
the poster presentation
if you guys have any further question
please feel free to put that down in the
chat section and i am happy to take it
up
if not then that brings us to the end of
today's ionic session i had a great
experience talking and interacting with
all of you
we definitely learned a lot and got
some great insights into systems biology
and network analysis from doctors and
gupta thanks thanks to dr center once
again for his time
and
if you want to contact us
uh any time later on please feel free to
send me an email in the email ids that i
have shared in the chat marketing and
communications at the refined bio and i
will be happy to answer all your
questions
having said that that brings us to the
end of today's ionic session we will
again meet on february 11th at 3 pm cst
until then
take care thank you so much for joining
us
and i wish you a very good evening see
you soon
yeah buddy i will send the
link to
[Music]
whatsapp by email when i shared the
recording of the session so you can use
that to join us
you